bonsoir et bienvenue très heureuse de
vous retrouver dans Ça vous regarde ce
soir une des plus grandes signatures du
journal Le Monde bonsoir Sylvie Koffman
bonsoir et merci d'être notre grand
témoin ce soir vous publierz les
aveuglés chez Stock ou comment la France
et l'Allemagne se sont complètement
leurés sur Vladimir Poutine pendant des
années de Paris à Berlin en passant par
Kiev Varsovie ou encore Washington vous
avez rassemblé dans un grand réc
historique passionnant bourré
d'anecdotes et de témoignages clés les
raisons de cet aveuglement on va en
parler tout à l'heure vous nous direz
aussi si Poutine peut se cacher derrière
le conflit au Proche Orient notre grand
débat ce soir où sont passés les
économies pour la sécurité sociale les
députés devaent trouver plus d'un
milliard pour limiter le trou de la SC
pas facile d'autant que le gouvernement
a renoncé à ponctionner dans les caisses
de retraite complémentaire alors qui va
payer nous en débattons dans un instant
avec mes invités sur ce plateau enfin
nous affranchi ce soir le billet philo
de Nathan de vert le regard sur la
société de Thomas Lestavel et puis
Bourbon express avec ela moningava voilà
pour le menu on y va Sylvie Koffman ça
vous regarde c'est tout de
[Musique]
suite la chasse aux économies a donc été
lancée les députés débattaient de depuis
hier du projet de loi de financement de
la sécurité sociale et sans surprise le
493 vient d'être déclenché il y a
quelques minutes par la première
ministre dans l'hémicycle mais la
surprise elle est venue du gouvernement
hier en renonçant à ponctionner dans les
retraites complémentaire et bien le
gouvernement constate un manque de
plusieurs milliards d'euros c'était aux
députés de les trouver pour contenir le
trou de la Sécu alors comment mieux
soigner tout en faisant des économies on
en débat ce soir avec vous Louis marger
bonsoir bonsoir merci d'être là vous
êtes député renaissance de sonélois vous
débattez avec votre confrère Arthur de
la porte bonsoir député socialiste du
Calvados bonsoir Nathalie coutinet
bonsoir bienvenue économiste de la santé
enseignante chercheur à l'université
Sorbonne Paris Nord enfin bonsoir sabéa
bouchacour bienvenue à vous vous êtes
directrice prévention qualité de vie au
travail chez le courtier en assurance
Diot siassi et vous venez de publier à
la Fondation jeanjorest une note
sur les arrêts de travail au cœur de ce
projet de loi intitulé les absents n'ont
pas toujours tort alors Sylvie Koffman
on est loin de votre terrain de
prédlection mais évidemment la santé
nous concerne tous les moyens aussi de
faire des économies n'hésitez pas à
intervenir quand vous souhaitez
interroger nos nos invités on commence
par d'abord ce qui électrise les
partenaires sociaux mais aussi
l'opposition aller piocher dans les
caisses de retraite complémentaires pour
trouver des économies c'est le chrono de
blo tout de suite
bonsoir mon cher Stéphane blackakovski
bonsoir Miriam bonsoir à toutes et tous
alors et bien agir Arco on a débattu
aujourd'hui à l'Assemblée du PLFSS
j'aime bien le dire enfin le projet de
loi de financement de la Sécurité social
vous savez que le gouvernement cherche à
réduire les déficits dans ce domaine
aussi donc il avait prévu 3 milliards un
peu plus de 3 milliards d'économie pour
2024 mais en fait ce n'est pas si simple
en effet pour parvenir il à ça il avait
prévu de ponctionner environ 1 milliard
dans les caisses donc de l'agir Carco
cette caisse de retraite complémentaire
des salaries du privé qui est géré par
les partenaires sociaux donc elle est
d'ailleurs plutôt bien géré même très
bien géré par les partenaires sociaux
puisque vous voyez que le montant des
cotisations perçues dépasse de 5
milliards celui des des prestations
versé pas d'endettement et donc si bien
que au fil des années la 68 milliards
d'euros de réserve ça paraît énorme
attention ça correspond à seulement 9
mois de versement des prestations donc
ce n'est pas si énorme que ça ça peut en
avoir l'air n'empêche selon le
gouvernement ce qui justifie qu'on
pioche ce milliard dans les caisses de
lagir lagirque Arco c'est le fait que
bien ce milliard il vient de l'effet
produit par la réforme des retraite on
écoute l'explication d'Olivier lot nous
considérons qu'il y a 1illard2 millions
d'euros qui vont bénéficier à GIR Carco
en 2026 uniquement par la réforme et
nous considérons comme légitime que
cette part des excédents liés à la
réforme puisse être mobilisé pour
participer au financement d'un régime de
solidarité alors autant dire que les
partenaires sociaux étaient vend debout
contre cette décision alors regardez que
la CGT s'oppose au gouvernement rien de
très étonnant en revanche que le MF soit
exactement sur la même ligne que la CGT
ça n'arrive pas si souvent ce qui
indigne en fait les partenaires sociaux
c'est que au début octobre ils ont
décidé ensemble après un vote d'utiliser
ce fameux milliard pour revaloriser les
retraites et donc voilà main le
gouvernement décide de remettre la M m
sur le milliard par le biais de cet
amendement donc un bras de fer peut être
envisagé avec les partenaires sociaux
mais ce qui inquiète un peu le
gouvernement c'est au cas où
l'opposition s'emmêlerait regardez il y
a déjà eu des tribunes publiées
notamment au début octobre par Marine Le
Pen sur ce sujet mais ce qui inquiète le
plus le gouvernement c'est la
perspective d'une motion de censure vous
vous souvenez que lors de la réforme des
retraites le groupe lotte avait déposé
une mçon de censure qui avait échoué à
seulement 9 voix près et bien on
s'inquiète notamment l'ésée à l'idée que
ça puisse se reproduire regardez le
président du groupot a été reçu en tête
à- tête par le président Macron c'est
signe malgré tout qu'on soigne ses
relation avec Bertran Pancher à l'Élysée
mais ça n'a pas suivi pas suffit le
groupe est inflexible on écoute n ne
souhaitons pas que la ponction soit
effectuée que ce n'est pas le sens du
travail qui est mené aujourd'hui avec
les organisations syndicales et
patronnales et que le gouvernement doit
reculer sur cette question bref le
gouvernement a reculé un peu de peur de
voir l'opposition se mobiliser autour
d'une motion de de censure il a a donc
préféré retirer l'amendement en question
mais attention écoutons attentivement ce
qu'a dit Thomas
CASNAV nous ne déposerons ah on a fa le
ministre du c'est pourquoi à ce stade
nous ne déposerons pas d'amendement
réduisant les recettes du régime agir
Carco alors j'espère que vous avez bien
entendu à ce stade don ce qui suggère
qu'il y aura peut-être un stade
ultérieur on sera tenté de remettre cet
amendement sur la table à moins bien sûr
de trouver une solution pour faire des
économies mais là je suis sûr que nos
experts ont plein d'idées hein merci
beaucoup justement on va parler des
autres mesures hein dans dans ce texte
mais quand même c'était un gros morceau
vous vous l'enterrez Louis Marguerite
cette idée d'aller puiser dans cette
caisse de retraite complémentaire non
d'abord le débat était très cristallisé
en effet je note quand même que chez les
organisations patronales comme syndical
les les avis n'étaient pas tous
convergents euh et queil y avait des
nuances auss de barrage était quand même
bien age mais quand on rentre dans le
détail parce qu'en réalité il y a des
paramètres de cette équipe effectivement
c'est un régime qui est géré par les
partenaires sociaux uniquement dans dans
lequel l'État n'est pas parti n'est pas
membre du des organes de gouvernance il
n'a pas de décision et pourtant ce sont
des éléments des éléments financiers que
l'on retrouve dans ce qu'on appelle le
déficit des administrations publiques
donc effectivement on peut avoir un
intérêt à regarder quel peut être
l'effet juste pour ce qui s'est passé
c'est que le gouvernement il a eu raison
de le faire il a renvoyé à nouveau la
discussion au partenaires sociaux pour
trouver quel est le bon point
d'équilibre pour pour que on puisse
effectivement il puissent gérer le
régime parce que c'est évidemment tout à
fait légitime qui le gère comme ils le
font depuis le début d'une part mais
pour autant effectivement considérer que
il y a eu des
effets sur le principe vous comprenez
que les cadres se dire ils sont gonflés
quand même voilà une caisse bien gérée
il va bien falloir revaloriser aussi les
pensions on va travailler plus longtemps
et hop on prendrait dans cette caisse
bien sûr mais pour autant on peut on est
on est aussi en droit de se se dire que
dans une réforme qui a été qui a pas été
simple qui a été contestée en plus on
sait les conditions Mo je l'ai soutenu
mais qui dans dans dans les conditions
dans lesquelles elle a été adoptée qu'il
y a des effets bénéfiques à cette
réforme c'est 1 milliard c'est
probablement 3 en 2026 et en 2027 d'près
trouver pourer préjection bien sûr mais
tout tout le sujet c'est qu'il puisse
trouver un accord et je suis sûr que le
bon sens le l'emportera alors Arthur de
laapte à ce stade il y a le 493 qui est
déposé on n pas le détail du texte mais
a priori il y aura pas un retour de
cette ponction dans dans la version 493
déposé par la première ministre il y a
quelques minutes vous sur le principe
vous étiez farouche m'en contontre après
tout regardez 68 milliards de réserves 1
milliard ça va pas ruiner cette caisse
he en fait la question c'est pas est-ce
qu'il y a 68 milliards de réserves et 1
milliards d'euros la question c'est le
respect du dialogue social cet
après-midi la CGT a signé l'accord qui
avait déjà été signé par le meddeef et
l'ensemble des organisations syndicales
qui va se traduire par une
revalorisation des pensions d'un peu
plus de 4 % l'an prochain ça c'est du
concret et ce que veut le gouvernement
finalement c'est fragiliser à la fois le
dialogue social puisqu'il y a un accord
de l'ensemble des des partenaires
sociaux syndicats et patronat mais aussi
prendre dans les poches des retraités
pour leur faire payer finalement le coût
de la réforme des retraite c'est ça
qu'il veut faire parce que qu'on le
veuille ou non et c'est pour cela aussi
que le gouvernement recule c'est qu'il
est mal à l'aise c'est que derrière si
on prend ce milliard ben il faudra bien
le faire payer à quelqu'un et c'est
d'ailleurs ce qu'il demande aux
partenaires sociaux le gouvernement il
dit ok cette fois-ci ça passe je vais
peut-être valider votre accord mais
demain il faudra que vous me disiez où
est-ce que je vais aller chercher mes
économies c'est entre 1 et 3 milliards à
horizon 2030 donc c'est que le début
hein alors justement on va regarder avec
vous Nathalie coutinet les les chiffres
le trou de la SCU il s'agit pas de de le
ramener à zéro évidemment mais de le
contenir 8,8 milliards 2023 11,2 en 2024
15,,8 en 25 17,9 en
2026 ce déficit va doubler en 3 ans à
quoi est-ce essentiellement dû alors
c'est dû à plusieurs choses c'est dû
d'abord au au fait que la population
s'accroit et que quand la population
s'accroit bah il y a aussi plus de gens
qui ont besoin d'être soignés il y a
aussi une population qui vieillit donc
ça nécessite aussi des soins il y a
également le fait qu'il y a eu des
revalorisations salariales pour les
Hospitaliers notamment après le le
segéure de la santé donc il y a ensemble
d'éléments qui viennent et puis j'ai
covid faut encore absorber sans doute un
peu de covid mais il y a aussi ce qu'il
faudrait qu'on intègre peut-être
complètement c'est le fait que les soins
coûtent de plus en plus cher ils sont
aussi plus techniques ils sont aussi de
meilleure qualité les médicaments sont
plus chers donc il y a tout un ensemble
de facteurs qui font que les soins sont
plus cher et donc je trouve assez
paradoxal que depuis plusieurs années
face à des soins dont les prix
augmentent dont le coût augmente on
veuille systématiquement réduire le
déficit de la Sécurité sociale pourquoi
il y aurait pas un consensus politique
pour dire la santé coûte plus cher parce
que on est aussi mieux soigné hein
l'espérance de vie les gains en
espérance de vie sont fantastiques alors
c'est rare d'entendre ça de la part des
économistes euh on y va on creuse parce
que vous êtes pas du tout sur la ligne
de la cure de rigueur prenée par Bercy
hein oui mais bon merci à ces objectif
non mais ça veut pas dire qu'il y a plus
de de déficit ça peut aussi vouloir dire
qu'il faut augmenter les recettes de la
sécurité sociale bah en augmentant les
cotisations sociales il y a un espèce de
de dogme absolu depuis des années de ne
pas augmenter les cotisations social
alors que ça serait sans doute une
meilleure solution regardez le
déremboursement des soins dantaires
partiellement puisque c'est passé de de
70 % à 60 %. qui va payer les mutuels
comment les mutuels vont se financer et
bien en augmentant les cotisations les
primes d'assurance donc finalement ça va
sortir de la porte de la poche des
ménage donc pourquoi vouloir privatiser
le financement de la sécurité sociale
alors que il serait tout à fait possible
d'augmenter les cotisations vous allez
me répondre compétitivité et cetera ok
même des salariés mais moi
personnellement je préférais payer plus
de cotisation sociale pour avoir un
système de santé plus solidaire et plus
juste plutôt que de me référer à des
complémentaires qui sont
fondamentalement non solidaire et donc
injuste oui Marguerite vous répond non
mais je un peu plus de
cotisationp à des frais de santé il peut
y avoir un choix sur est-ce que on
augmente les recettes ou on baisse les
dépenses en tout cas en tout cas non pas
qu'on les baisse mais en tout cas qu'on
on contient un peu le leur augmentation
parce qu'elles augmente naturellement
par du fait de l'inflation naturelle
parce qu' un C nombre de prestations qui
sont quand on regarde les dépenses là je
par
mais les dépenses quand on regarde le
fameux Onam pour ceux qui nous regardent
c'est un peu jargonant c'est l'objectif
national de dépens d'assurance maladie
et projeté à
247,6 milliards d'euros contre 245 en
avril pour se donner un tout petit peu
voilà les mesures de l'ampleur de nos
dépenses en matière de santé ce que ce
que je ce que je voulais préciser c'est
que d'abord il y a pas un pays au monde
qui a qui a la protection sociale qu'on
a ça veut pas dire que qu'elle est
suffisante en tant que telle on peut se
débattre et c'est le débat que nous
avons eu et que nous aurons à nouveau
dans les parties suivantes du PLFSS ça
c'est le premier point ensuite
effectivement vous avez raison vous avez
raison non mais il y aura d'autres
parties aura sans doute d'autres 49 an
ça interdit pas de se poser la question
et de débattre quand on peut le faire
sérieusement il y a un point qui est
essentiel c'est qu'effectivement un
certain nom de dépenses augmente très
fort notamment des maladies qui peuvent
être des maladies graves je pense au
cancer je pense au maladies chroniqu
effectivement ça n'interdit pas de se
poser la question quand bien même les
dépenses augmentent et qu'on a une
couverture globale qui reste à peu près
enfin assez élevé comme comme ça a été
le cas pendant des années en France euh
de se poser la question d'effectivement
de contenir un certain nombre de dépense
c'est ça justement ou parce que il
fallait faire 3,5 milliards he d'euros
d'économie avec ce
budgetom enfin de moindre dépense de
moindre dépense ce milliard auquel vous
renoncez vous trouvez où une par une
grosse partie 66 % des dépenses de santé
c'est des des malades qui sont en
infection longue durée donc déjà ces
maladesl euh pe pas on d'ailleurs il
touche pas il est pas question d'
toucher non mais heureusement enfin
j'espère bien je préfère le préciser
c'esti Mar de manœuvre sont très
faibles alors juste pour compenser ce
milliard auquel vous renoncez est-ce que
vous avez alors avance 493 trouver ce
milliard quelque part d'ord le milliard
en tant que tel il il existe de toute
façon le ministre casnab l'a dit vous
l'avez vous avez montrer l'extrait on
renvoie aux partenaires sociaux parce
que effectivement ils sont légitimes
pour discuter effectivement de ce qui va
se passer l'année prochaine les années
suivantes et cetera ça c'est le premier
point et ensuite dans ce dans ce projet
de loi de finan sécurité sociale il y a
un certain nombre encore une fois de
moindres dépenses qu'on contient
notamment en terme de de prévention en
terme d'un meilleur contrôle et
notamment sur les fraudeurs et pas
uniquement euh une surconsommation de
médicaments comme on a pu l'entendre
mais aussi pour des mauvaises
déclarations URSAF et un certain nombre
de sujet alle ça c'est du truc concret
ça va parler aux gens puis je vous donne
la parole SAB bouchacour dans dans un
instant et si c'est économie se trouvait
dans la chasse aux arrêts de travail les
salariés sont de plus en plus nombreux à
se mettre en arrêt de travail plus d'un
actif sur deux a été absent au moins une
journée l'an dernier alors ça euh ça
peut être la solution ou pas explication
avec Stéphanie Despierre qui nous
détaille l'ensemble des mesures phares
de ce
texte l'une des principales mesures de
ce budget c'est la lutte contre la
fraude le gouvernement fait la chasse
aux arrêt malades de complaisance qui
coûte de plus en plus cher à la sécurité
sociale il y aura un renforcement des
contrôles à la fois des médecins et des
patients et la téléconsultation sera
mieux encadrée il ne sera plus possible
d'obtenir un arrêt de travail de plus de
3 jours ou un renouvellement par
consultation vidéo sauf si c'est avec
votre médecin traitant ou si vous pouvez
prouver qu'aucun professionnel n'a pu
vous recevoir pour renouveler votre
congé maladie concernant les médicaments
les pharmacies pourront dans certains
cas délivrer des antibiotiques à l'unité
avec un double objectif faire des
économies mais surtout limiter les
pénuries il y a plus de 3700 médicaments
en rupture ou en risque de rupture de
stock en ce moment en France
ce budget confirme plusieurs mesures
pour les moins de 26 ans en pharmacie
les préservatifs masculins et féminins
seront gratuits les protections
périodiques seront remboursées enfin il
prévoit d'expérimenter la prise en
charge du baby
blues alors Saba bouchacour que sait-on
sur ces arrêts de travail abusifs est-ce
qu'on en a une idée en quantité que dit
l'assurance maladie alors on sait que
les la sinistralité arrêt de travail à
augmente for maintenant depuis de
nombreuses années donc on a eu l'impact
covid qui a marqué des pics mais
indépendamment du covid on a une des
arrêt de travail qui augmente et
effectivement dans dans ce qui vient
d'être dit dans ce projet de loi il y a
il y a des mesures qui sont prises
plutôt coercitives sur le contrôle où on
on va l'article 27 dit que à partir de
de maintenant lorsque l'employeur va
demander un contrôle si l'employeur le
contrôleur mandaté par l'employeur
considère que l'arrêt n'est pas justifié
il y aura suspension automatique des
indemnités journalières alors que
jusqu'à présent il y avait une contreexp
on va venir sur les modalités de ce
nouveau contrôle par l'employeur enfin
c'est quand même un médecin qui va
examiner la personne j'imagine
expliquez-nous pourquoi il y a ces 8 %
de plus d'arrêts de de travail constater
est-ce que c'est parce que tout
simplement on travail plus vieux ou
est-ce qu'il y a d'autres raisons on a
les motifs les raisons
socio-démographique sur une population
active qui travaille plus longtemps qui
est de plus en plus importante donc ça
c'est des des c'est tout à fait
mécanique hein en terme de de d'absence
les seniors sont plus absents que les
autres et on a plus de seniors parmi les
actifs mais c'est vrai qu'on a une une
hausse de l'absentéisme qui est surtout
portée par l'absentéisme long donc on
parle beaucoup de l'absentéisme court de
de la panne de réveil du lundi matin
mais en réalité ce qui nous ce qui ce
qui pèse le plus dans nos dépenses
publiques aujourd'hui sont les arrêts
très longs donc on est on est sur des
enjeux de de prévention sur une
temporalité beaucoup plus longue en
réalité donc certes il y a un un un
sujet ob de de de de contrôler de
sanctionner les abus potentiels et et et
les mesures qui sont prises vont dans ce
sensl mais c'est vrai que le sujet il
est plutôt sur les arrêt longs puisque
la la hausse donc pour vous il y a plus
je dirais d'actifs plus fragile qu'avant
plutôt que de véritables abus en
quantité c'est ça en tout cas c'est
enfin c'est c'est un c'est
multifactoriel c'estàdire que nous on n
pas le le sentiment que les les les on n
pas de statistique nous on est courtier
de de fraude qui exploserait enfin
encore une fois la elle est elle est
elle est particulièrement complexe à
prouver hein notamment sur des
pathologies qui sont difficilement
vérifiables et cetera mais mais en tout
cas aujourd'hui les contrôles existent
la sécurité sociale partager le chiffre
de 300000 contrôles par an avec 20 % de
contrôle qui donnait lieu à une
suspension des indemnités journalièr
l'assurance maladie parle d'un cas sur 5
qui ne justifierait pas un un arrêt de
travail et on est vraiment déjà sur
300000 arrêts ciblés he c'estd que c'est
pas un cas sur 5 des arrêts en général
Arthur de la porte euh il y a il y a cet
article c'est vrai l'article 27 qui fait
qu'on va simplifier un peu les contrôles
c'est l'employeur qui décide de
contrôler un salarié qui est en arrêt de
travail en envoyant un médecin chez lui
euh mais c'est c'est une RUP en fait
c'est nous on a évidemment voter contre
cet article mais le problème c'est qu'on
a voté contre en commission et ça va me
permettre quand même de dire quelque
chose Z ce soir on a des discussions on
parle de la fraude on parle de la
manière dont on peut financer nos
dépenses d'assurance maladie on parle de
choses comme l'ager Carco le problème
c'est qu'on en parle sur LCP mais on en
parlera pas dans l'hémicycle parce que
la première ministre elle est arrivée ce
soir elle a mis un 493 avant même qu'on
engage véritablement les débats et que
il est probable que comme elle l'a fait
sur le projet de loi de finance avant
même qu'on arrive à discuter de tout ça
on soit de nouveau stopper quand on va
essayer de reprendre sur la 2uxème
partie sur la 3ème partie et cetera donc
on va se prendre des 493 répétition et
on ne pourra pas aborder les sujets qui
touchent le quotidien la vie des
Français et pour moi ça c'est le
sentiment d'une injustice terrible mais
c'est aussi le signe d'une dév
vitalisation du Parlement parce que les
collègues de la majorité ne sont pas
venus cet après-midi on a gagné
quasiment tous les votes l'opposition
parce que la majorité considère que ça
ne sert plus à rien de venir débattre
est-ce que pour vous ça aurit été plus
utile parce qu'à la fin c'est toujours
le 493 sur les textes budgétaires quand
on n' pas de majorité absolue est-ce que
si le débat avait été au bout des
articles ça aurait été déjà mieux vous
savez Michel Rocard a eu une utilisation
importante du 493 mais il a toujours
fait à la fin et en reprenant les
amendements adoptés de l'opposition on a
fait adopter des amendements en
commission par exemple des affaires
sociales moi j'ai obtenu un amendement
sur la fiscalité des boissons
alcoolisées aujourd'hui vous avez ce
qu'on appelle les prémix avec les
boissons aromatisées qui sont la porte
d'entrée vers l'alcool et j'ai réussi à
faire adopter cet amendement avec le
soutien de collèguue de la majorité du
MoDem notamment et on a réussi voilà à
faire potentiellement une politique de
santé publique et là on pourra pas en
discuter le gouvernement ne retiendra
pas mon amendement alors que je suis sûr
qu'on aurait pu trouver une majorité
là-dessus c'est le c'est le la
temporalité du 493 c'est vrai que depuis
cette nouvelle législature depuis cette
rentrée parlementaire 493 sur les textes
financiers ils sont dégainés tout de
suite vous l'assumez cette stratégie
vous dites à l'opposition même pas le
temps de discuter on connaît la fin donc
de toute façon on passe en force
d'entrer de jeu mais ce que je dis à mon
collègue de la porte que j'ai connu plus
nuancé plus mesuré c'est que mesuré j'ai
pas éé c'est que c'est que d'abord ce
débat il est lu en commission en effet
ça était dit des dizaines d'heures et
heureusement et tant mieux all au bout
du texte d'ailleurs tous les articles
ont été votés à l'exception du texte en
effet effectivement parce que
structurellement la configuration de
l'Assemblée nationale elle se retrouve
dans les commissions fait que fait que
si toutes leex voté en commissioneli qui
AR après sur le fond parce que ceux qui
nous regardent ça va peut-être changer
pour eux d'avoir
comp oui mais on compare sou de
l'utilisation du 493 encore une fois si
on peut l'éviter on préfère enfin nous
les premiers seulement là on est sur des
textes qui sont qui sont très importants
parce que c'est ceux qui valident la
politique globale du gouvernement et
donc c'est normal que les oppositions
soient moins encline à vous à voter le
493 le seul sujet c'est que elle vote
elle vote contre le 493 peut-être demain
la motion de sens S pour des raisons
souvent strictement opposé les unes avec
les autres vou mê pas qu'on débat le
prier et dernier parce que vous comparez
souvent à Michel rard qui effectivement
é un grand Premier ministre c'était
quand même à une époque où le pal FSS
n'existait pas et il il était pas cindé
en trois parties donc effectivement on
dit 493 sur 493 en réalité pour
expliquer aux un aux autres c'est que il
y a plusieurs parties dans le texte en
plus il reviendra en seconde lecture et
donc c'est ça qui surcune vous sazond
sur le fond moi je bien
rép vou quand même qu'on a ce pointl
parce que c'est important de dire que
malheureusement a pas parlé fort
probablement de la question des arrêts
de travail or qu'est-ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui quand vous avez un arrêt de
travail il vous est prescrit par un
médecin votre médecin traitant médec
médecine du travail et vous pouvez être
contrôlé vous pouvez être contrôlé même
à la demande de l'employeur mais c'est
un médecin qui est mandaté par la
Sécurité sociale qui vient demain
qu'est-ce qui se passera c'est
l'employeur lui-même qui pourra désigner
son médecin ce qui fait que c'est
évidemment pas un intermédiaire qui est
neutre il vient pour essayer de rétablir
l'Assurance Maladie pour toujours faire
ses propres cont pour toujours le faire
mais c'est quelque chose qui va
déséquilibrer le rpport for de force
alors qu'aujourd'hui il était assez
satisfaisant
parille juste une dernière pe sur la
question de la fraude la fraude sociale
la fraude aux cotisations social parce
que c'est ça qui c'est quelque chose qui
est extrêmement marginal et les de tiers
de la fraude c'est pas lié aux individus
c'est lié aux employeurs qui font de la
fraude de cotisation sociale et c'est
lié égalementors expque ça c'est les
médecins on parle de qui c'est de la
c'est de la non déclaration c'est des
médecins aussi par exemple qui vont
faire des systèmes de surfacturation
quand on regarde la dépense de l'hôpital
public c'est des pharmaciens par exemple
il y a des pharmaciens il y a une
soantaine de pharmaciens qu' ont
détourné quasiment 3 ou 400 millions
d'euros j'ai plus exactement ch vous
votez contre la la lutte contre la frate
sociale des médecin des pharmaci la
lutte contre les Arrus tr/ c'est des
professionnels de santé qui sont
responsables de la fraude c'est pas les
d'accord avec ça ce sont les
professionnels qui fraudent pas les les
salariés malad y a de la fraude bien sûr
qu'il y a aussi bien sûr des gens qui
fraudent on va pas on va pas être bé
mais çaa rentrer beaucoup d'argent terme
de masse évidemment les fraudes allur
SAF qui sont beaucoup plus importantes
que les fraudes des des des ménages Faou
des patients si vous voulez et je
voulais revenir également sur les sur
les arrêts maladies parce qu'il y a eu
beaucoup de travaux justement qui ont
été fait sur les arrêts maladies et ce
dont on s'aperçoit c'est que de plus en
plus de jeunes donc de de jeunes actifs
sont un AR maladie souvent pour des
raisons psychologiques et ça renvoie
aussi à quelque chose qu'il faudrait
traiter c'est que la France est un des
pays dans lequel la souffrance au
travail est la plus importante ça a été
montré par différents travaux notamment
de laadès récemment donc plutôt que de
vouloir sanctionner ou contrôler il
faudrait PE peut-être aussi s'interroger
sur pourquoi une partie des salariés
notamment les plus jeunes sont en arrêt
de travail pour des raisons
psychologiques et et améliorer sans
doute au niveau des entreprises du
dialogue social peut-être qu'il y aurait
là aussi un moyen de prévenir un certain
nombre d'arrêt maladies sachant qu'en
plus la médecine du travail est plutôt
en crise et qu'on en manque beaucoup
dans les entreprises mais moi je suis je
suis d'accord avec ce que dit mon
collègue de la porte comme quoi ça peut
arriver et notamment sur le fait que en
effet quand on parle des de la fraude
c'est toutes les fraudes et et il en a
un certain nom je suis d'accord sur sur
de notamment des fraudes aux cotisations
effectivement avec notamment le travail
dissimulé le travail sous sous sous sous
déclaré et ceeta ça ça existe il faut le
renforcer c'est très important il y a
aussi des fraudes aux prestations et
quand on a annoncé le plan fraude et je
crois que ça faisait plutôt l'unanimité
parmi les les parties dit gouvernement
en tout cas républicain ils ont ils ont
ils ont tous acquaessé en disant
effectivement il faut s'attaquer à
toutes les fraudes frude fiscale fr ça
c'est le premier point deuxième point il
est pas interdit sans changer
drastiquement les grands paramètres de
notre couverture sociale parce qu'au
fond on y est tous attachés c'est la MO
les dépenses publiques on a une
couverture qui est très importante et il
est pas question de changer les grands
fondamentaux en revanche les indemnités
jour derrièr en effet elles ont
massivement augmenté ces dernières
années il y a peut-être des bonnes
raisons à cela en effet effectivement un
peu de viissement population c'est vrai
aussi donc il y a des bonnes raisons et
il y a peut-être des raisons
effectivement qui et c'est ça qu'on
cherche àerouchour on va parler d'autres
mesures notamment en matière de
prévention parce que voilà par exemple
se vacciner contre le papiom virirus ça
peut aussi faire des économie sur des
maladies à traiter qui n'arriveront pas
par par à l'avenir les arrêts de travail
par téléconsultation
ne devront pas excéder 3 jours ça c'est
aussi dans les luttes contre les les
fraudes aux arrêts travail ça c'est
indispensable selon vous alors il y a
effectivement enfin a eu plusieurs on a
tous entendu parler de de de de de
fraude de de vente d'arrêt de travail
frauduleux donc mais c'est assez
anecdotique en réalité et puis rappelons
que nous on avait on avait un taux
d'absentéisme sur notre dernière
observatoire qui était à 564 en en 2022
les arrêts de moins de 4 jours c'était 0
15 % d'accord fait c'est marginal c'est
marginal il y a des des choses sur les
médicaments beaucoup de dérboursements
dans ce PLFSS vous aviez peut-être une
question je crois sur le sujet oui à
propos du sujet que vous avez diffusé
tout à l'heure sur les médicaments est
dans beaucoup de pays étrangers on vend
les médicaments à l'unité et ça évite le
gaspillage en France on a toujours vendu
les les boîtes de comprimé par 20 par 30
et et il en reste je suppose est-ce que
ça c'est une économie possible ou pas
est-ce que c'est l'industrie
pharmaceutique qui bloque moi j'y suis
j'y suis totalement favorable et c'est
on fait un premier pas dans ce PLFSS où
en effet pour un certain nombre de
médicaments qui sont en tension on
prévoit effectivement une vente à
l'unité donc concrètement vous prenez la
boîte et vous n donnez au patients enfin
le pharmacien des livr patient
uniquement les les les comprimés ou en
tout cas les éléments les les molécules
dont il a besoin pour son traitement
donc moi j j suis assez favorable en
effet et j'imagine que c'est le sens de
votre question la question hêement des
franchises parce que ça ça a beaucoup
alors voilà franchise sur certains médic
qui ét
pré que je peux comprendre non mais
c'est un point c'est un point débat que
je peux largement comprendre seulement
le sujet c'est pas de dérembourser c'est
de se dire que d'abord les prix la
franchise n'a jamais été augmenté je
crois sur les 7 ou les 8 dernières
années ça c'est le premier élément le
deuxième élément l'élément c'est que on
ne touche pas aux maladies chroniques
c'est très important et l'immense
majorité je vous l'aveis dit ce sont des
maladies chroniques concrètement ce sont
des gens qui ont besoin de prendre des
médicaments très souvent parce qu'ils
ont des maladies donc voilà qui doivent
être traités soigner régulièrement avec
ces médicaments là en revanche là ce
qu'on touche c'est effectivement des
plus petites pathologies cherche pas les
comparés entre elles ça une pathologie
une pathologie du quotidien où en effet
on fait passer la franchise la franchise
de 50 à 100 € c'est-à-dire que vous avez
une franchise de 1 € par boîte de
médicaments ce n'est pas dans le texte
parce qu'en fait c'est c'est fait par
voie réglementaire j'ai cru comprendre
que le gouvernement était plutôt
favorable à le faire moi je trouve que
c'est c'est aussi un effet de
respponsabilation pour encore une fois
des petites putologies qui ne reviennent
pas souvent dans l'année et et voilà
donc c'est Arthur de la porte mais
évidemment que on peut pas être d'accord
avec ça parce que c'est 10 % des
Français 10 % des Français qui vont
payer 50 € de plus et pour certains ça
peut représenter énormément vous voyez
bien à quel point on le voit tous les
jours hein des personnes qui n'arrivent
pas à boucler leur fin de mois 50 €
c'est beaucoup et donc au moins 10 %
despectateurs je pense même que si on
suppose que les téléspectateurs sont un
peu plus âgés que la moyenne des
Français ça peut arriver c'est
aujourd'hui les personnes les plus âgées
qui le plus atteindre le plafond de la
franchise donc les 50 € qui vont passer
à 100 € demain et nous évidemment on a
dénoncé cette injustice mais on a aussi
dénoncer le manque d'information de la
part du gouvernement et ce que je trouve
assez assez assez étrange en terme de
d'éclairage du débat public c'est que le
ministre a dit à mon collègue Jérôme GED
hier puisque vous voulez des
informations là-dessus vous n'avez qu'à
aller vous renseigner parce que Jérôme
gage a ce pouvoir c'est le seul avec un
autre collègue de la majorité à pouvoir
aller au ministère chercher les
documents donc qu'a fait Jérôme gage ce
matin il est allé au ministère chercher
les documents que le gouvernement V pour
dire ça allit représenter 800 millions
d'euros l'an prochain et que ça allait
peser sur les plus âgés et sur 10 % des
Français ça c'est quand même quelque
chose qui est pas négligeable et ça nous
dit aussi un peu quelque chose du débat
public parce que demain quand vous ferez
une radio bah vous allez payer 50
centimes 1 € plus quand vous achèterz
quand
vous la franchise elle va passer de 1 à
2 € sur les médic m dans votre
exemple Act des actes médicaux comme des
radios par exemple naalie sur ces
questions de franchise qui vont
augmenter alors ce que je voulais juste
apporter un tout petit point de
précision par rapport à ce qui a été dit
c'est que pour les malades qu'on des
malades chronique donc qui sont en al
les médicaments qui ne sont pas les
inections longue duré ce sont uniquement
les médicaments qui sont liés à la
pathologie c'estàdire que des gens qui
ont des maladies très graves des cancers
par exemple effectivement ne payent pas
les les médicaments qui sont liés à leur
pathologie mais s'ils ont des
pathologies associées et c'est souvent
le cas hein les traitements peuvent
générer des effets indésirables et
cetera sur ces médicaments là ils n'ont
pas le l'infection longue durée donc là
ils auront ils seront la franchise
s'appliquera sur eux donc c'est
effectivement des gens qui ont plutôt
des maladies chroniques plutôt des
gensagies qui vont payer ces 100 €
plutôt de 50 jusque là donc c'est la
double peine à vous à vous entendre ça
bouchac ce qu'il faut aussi avoir en
tête c'est que on a d'un côté les
dépenses publiques mais de l'autre le
système de protection sociale qui repose
aussi sur les régimes de prévoyance
santé qui sont aujourd'hui financés par
les entreprises et les salariés
c'estàdire que d'une manière ou d'une
autre au bout du bout quelqu'un va payer
donc lors enfin on est dans un régime où
les les dépenses sont mutualisées donc
on a tous effectivement plutôt envie de
se responsabilisé sur les dépenses
puisque y compris dans les régimes de
prévoyance santé qui sont en entreprise
financé à minima 50 % par l'employeur et
le reste par le salarié ce qui n'est pas
pris en charge au départ sera pris en
charge par les complémentaires et au
bout du bout ça un coût pour l'employeur
et pour le salarié sur la fiche de P
donc il faut aussi avoir en tête que les
dépenses resteront alors pour terminer
ce débat peut-être qu'on va s'arrêter
sur une notre d'accord sur les les
mesures en matière de prévention
gratuité du vaccin contre le
papiomavirus pour pour les collégiens
gratuité des préservatifs pour les moins
de 26 ans il y a également des des
mesures sur les culottes menstruelles
pour pour les femmes ça on se dit une
majorité claire et et franche dans
l'hémicycle sur ces mesuresl on peut le
souhaiter c'est que c'est à l'opposition
qu'il faut demander qu'il faut poser la
question et j'ajoute un dernier point
qui qui est passé un peu sous silence
mais il y a l'assiette des cotisations
des travailleurs indépendant qui touche
des centaines de milliers de Français
NOTAM et probablement plusieurs millions
sur lequel on va on va intégrer un
amendement ce intégrer un amendement
vous parlez tellement vite j'ai du mal à
vous suivreass c'est l'assiette de
cotisation des travailleurs indépendants
donc concrètement les artisans les
commerçants les professionnels Libé qui
verront dès demain ENF en tout cas dès
l'année prochaine leur leur conation un
petit peu baissé puisqu'on va revoir
leur modalité de calcul de leurs
assiettes bien prévention oui tout ce
qui peut êreous bien mais c'est dommage
un sujet qu'on a pas abordé je par juste
de le dire c'est l'hôpital public parce
que l'hôpital public va avoir ses
financement très peu augmenté voire
quasiment réduire puisque une grosse
partie de de des financements dehôpital
vont aller pour les les salaires des des
soignants et donc ça veut dire qu'on va
avoir un hôpital public qui va être
encore plus délabré que les années
précédentes et ça c'est vraiment dommage
et ça c'est uniquement dans le budget de
la SC que ça aurait pu être réglé on
peut pas faire ça dans un projet
partie la prév la prévention mais vous
savez qu'il y a un acteur important de
la prévention c'est santé publique
France qui voit son budget diminuer de
12 % probablement l'an prochain et moi
je suis membre du Conseil national du
sida j'ai été voir sida infau service
l'an prochain c'est 12 % de baisse du
budget c'est des postes en moins alors
que c'est essentiel pour la prévention
la lutte contre les maladies
sexuellement
transmiss sur la question des
cotisations sociales il y a eu un très
bon rapport de Jérôme Gedge et de Marc
ferci membre de la majorité qui disait
que les exonérations de cotisation
sociale audelà de 2,5 SMIC était pas
utile qu' y avait de l'argent à aller
chercher ce côté-là on
aura s'te financer ça n'a pas été fait
en tous les cas ceux qui nous regardent
auront un aperçu de ce qu'il y a dans ce
texte de loi donc adopté sans vote 493
déclenché par la première ministre on
verra la suite des différentes parties
budgétaires sur sur ce texte qui part
donc au Sénat merci à vous
merci d'être venu débattre sur LCP vous
restez avec moi Sylvie Koffman dans une
dizaine de minutes les parties pris de
nos affranchis ce soir le regard du
philosophe Nathan de vert sur les
mensonges du ramas après l'explosion qui
a touché l'hôpital de Gaza un coup de
gueule aussi ce soir celui de tomomas
Lestavel sur le manque d'ambition dans
la lutte contre l'addiction au jeu et
puis l'histoire du jour à l'assemblée de
quoi nous parlez-vous Elsa ce soir des
tensions tension à tous les étages dans
l'assemblée de l'hémicycle aux réunion
de groupe à tout à l'heure les amis mais
d'abord on va plonger avec vous Sylvie
Koffman dans 30 ans de ces cités dans
les aveuglés chez Stock et bien vous
raconter comment l'Europe l'Allemagne et
la France en tête n'ont absolument rien
compris au projet impérialiste de
Vladimir Poutine malgré les
avertissements malgré les précédents en
tchéie en geéorgie et en Crimée nos
dirigés nos dirigeants sont restés les
yeux fermés pourquoi et surtout comment
on voit ça dans l'invitation de Marco
pemier on en parle toutes les deux juste
après
si on vous invite Sylvie Koffman c'est
pour avoir votre regard sur cet ordre
mondial bouleversé le proche orient
s'embrase avec cette guerre entre Israël
et le Hamas sans oublier l'invasion de
l'Ukraine par la Russie c'est d'ailleurs
le sujet de votre livre avec une thèse
l'aveuglement des occidentaux sur
Vladimir Poutine de décennies d'illusion
de Washington Londres mais surtout de
Paris et Berlin jusqu'à
l'éclatement j'ai pr la décision
d'unetion
opé le projet autoritaire et
impérialiste du maître du kremmelin vous
l'avez observé de près décrit depuis 30
ans Sylvie Koffman vous la spécialiste
des relations internationales
éditorialiste au journal Le Monde grand
reporter ancienne correspondante à
Moscou vous avez couvert l'effondrement
du bloc soviétique de la chute du mur de
Berlin à la dissolution de l'URSS le
drapeau rouge frappé de la faussille du
marteau qui flottait au Fonton du
kremmelin sera abaissé des Occidentaux
naïfs sur la personnalité et les réelles
intentions de Vladimir Poutine malgré
les nombreux signaux alarmants massacre
du peuple Tchen en 2000 invasion de la
geéorgie en 2008 de la Crimée en 2014
des Occidentaux victimes aussi de la
duplicité du président russe ovationné
au boutenstag à Berlin en 2001 après un
discours prononcé en
allemand malgré certaines maladresses
bat le cœur fort est vivant de la Russie
ouvert à une coopération et un
partenariat à part entière je vous
remercie opération séduction réussi très
vite les trois plus grands pays de
l'Europe se retrouvent liés à Poutine la
France ne veut surtout pas humilier la
Russie au Royaume-Uni l'argent des
oligarques russes fait tourner
l'économie l'Allemagne elle devient
dépendante du gaz russe et à l'énergie
bon marché ce gazoduc va permettre à
l'Europe d'assurer son approvisionnement
régulier dans le futur
l'art d'endormir ses adversaires
aujourd'hui volodimir Zelinski accuse
Vladimir Poutine de soutenir le Hamas et
craint que le conflit ne détourne
l'attention de l'Ukraine alors
dites-nous Syvie Koffman la guerre au
Proche Orient profite-elle au maître du
cremelin réponse pour l'instant oui
malheureusement pour à deux titres
d'abord parce que toute notre attention
est pour des raisons très logique et
légitime est focalisé sur le proche
orient sur cette nouvelle guerre et puis
parce que pendant ce
temps le Poutine voit monter la colère
anti-occidentale dans notamment dans les
pays du Sud et ça c'est très bon pour
lui parce que il a il va ça va nourrir
sa propagande ça va nourrir son ses
appuis politiques donc donc laention
mondiale s'est détourné c'est une obè
pour Poutine oui qui qui relance son
offensive dans l'est de l'Ukraine en ce
moment et qui en profite sur le terrain
militaire au-delà quel quelle est la
stratégie de Poutine au Proche Orient
elle est compliquée à suivre on a
l'impression que d'un côté il s'affiche
plutôt ami de netanahou en Israël et en
même temps il arrive à garder des
relations avec tous les pays arabes aux
alentours comment la le comprendre alors
il a hérité de l'Union
soviétique une relation très profonde
avec le monde arabe ça c'est c'était
vraiment un une un marqueur de de la
politique étrangère soviétique euh mais
lui ce qu'il a fait c'est qu'il s'est
effectivement rapproché euh d'Israël euh
avec quelquefois des intérêts qui
convergeaient par exemple il se c'est
compliqué dans cette région évidemment
mais il se partage la surveillance du
ciel syrien par exemple il y a y a des
il a maintenant Poutine a réinvesti
c'est ça a repris la la la place de la
Russie au Moyen-Orient en en intervenant
en Syrie en 2015 pour euh en en fait
aider le le régime de Bachar al-Assad à
se rétablir joue un peu sur T les sur
les tableau mais là avec cette crise il
est en train de lâcher Israël il lâche
il a mis plus d'une semaine à à appeler
Benyamin netanahou après les attaques du
7 octobre et et cette ce lapse de temps
a été vraiment noté comme une volonté de
de prendre ses distances avec Israël
donc il prend et il se met très
nettement là dans le camp
anti-occidental du monde arabe alors
revenons aux aveuglés ce sont avant tout
les Français et les Allemands Paris et
Berlin qui n'ont rien vu venir de cette
invasion russe du 24 février 2022 on va
écouter le président ukrainien juste
après l'invasion on est en avril 2022
écoutez j'invite Madame Merkel et
Monsieur Sarkozi à visiter bcha et à
voir à quoi la politique de concession
envers la Russie a abouti à voir avec
leurs propres yeux les ukrainiens et les
Ukrainiennes
torturés voilà on est en avril et
volodomir zelensk cite Angela Merkel et
Nicolas sarzi ça n'est pas un hasard ils
ne sont plus au pouvoir et pour lui ils
ont ces deux chefs d'Ét là une part de
responsabilité pourquoi parce que tous
les deux en 2008 en avril 2008
exactement au cours d'un sommet de
l'OTAN à Bucarest ils se sont ils ont
empêché George George W Bush alors
président des États-Unis d'ouvrir la la
porte de l'OTAN à l'Ukraine et à la
geéorgie et vraiment ça c'est un c'est
c'est une une un sommet que je raconte
compte parce que je l'ai reconstitué
avec les avec les gens qui étaient là
avec les acteurs qui étaient là ils ont
gardent tous un souvenir d'une bataille
homérique entre Angela Merkel un peu
moins Nicolas Sarkozi mais qui était
quand même en soutien d'Angela Merkel
c'est elle qui menait vraiment la
bataille et Bush qui tenait absolument
il était en fin de mandat il tenait à à
laisser dans son
héritage cette
cette cette promesse de de pour de de
d'intégrer l'Ukraine dans l'OTAN pour
qu'elle puisse se défendre qu'elle soit
défendue en fait par l'OTAN la Russie
mais Merkel et Sarkozy ont fait échouer
cette stratégie voilà abritter un pays
sous l'ombrelle autant qui ne soit pas
un des pays de l'exurss éétait pour
Merkel une forme de quoi de danger de
provocation
oui oui Merkel et Sarkozy tous les deux
avaient peur de provoquer la Russie ils
avaient peur que ça ça soit pris
comme une voocation en effet par Moscou
parce que jusqu on avait intégré dans
l'OTAN les les pays les ex-pays du PACT
de Varsovie la Pologne on avait quand
même intégré les pays baltes les trois
pays baltes qui étaient eux des
républiques d'ancienne république de
l'URSS mais les pays baltes c'étaient un
peu différents parce qu'ils avaient été
intégrés par colonisés en fait par
l'URSS un peu plus tard que les autres
donc on avait fait un cas spécial mais
on disait l'Ukraine on savait que
c'était un gros morceau l'Ukraine on
savait que c'était un gros morceau mais
il y a des diplomates allemands qui
étaient à ce
sommet de de de l'OTAN 2008 qui ont
défendu cette position avec Merkel qui
l'ont aidé à à à élaborer ce ce
compromis terrible et qui maintenant
m'ont dit mais finalement on n'urait pas
dû finalement Poutine n'était pas en
mesure de faire la guerre à ce moment-là
il n'était pas assez fort il n'aurait
pas ré c'est une des nombreuses erreurs
parce qu'elles sont voilà se succède
d'une certaine façon c'est un
aveuglement qui persiste dans la durée
vous mentionner la Pologne les pays
baltes on va aller voir sur la carte ils
ont une limite ils sont limitrophes d'un
point de vue géographique avec la Russie
les avertissements ont été très nombreux
vous en parlez dans votre livre à
Varsovie en Lituanie en Lettonie en
Estonie et pourquoi il ne sont jamais
pris vraiment au sérieux parce que
justement ils ont été ces trois pays ces
trois petites républiques étaient donc
intégré de force à la à
l'URSS non ont vraiment lutté pour leur
indépendance à la fin de l'Union
soviétique elles ont eu un rôle pionnier
dans cette dans l'éclatement de de
l'URSS et les les Européens de l'Ouest
au sein de l'Union européenne une fois
qu'on les a intégrés on les écoutait
mais on se disait ils sont complètement
traumatisés on leur disait d'ailleurs
ils me l'ont raconté les d'anciens chefs
d'État et de gouvernement euh notamment
cette ancienne une présidente
lituanienne d'allé griba auskité qui est
une personnalité extraordinaire qui est
en ceinture noire de karaté euh et et
une femme très très forte qui a aussi
été commissaire européenne d'ailleurs à
Bruxelles euh elle ils ont pris
l'habitude qu'on leur disent mais vous
vous êtes euh vous êtes des des
desés vous êtes russophobe et vous
exagérez vous êtes exccessif et donc on
les écoutait gentiment mais on tenait
absolument pas compte de leurs
avertissements et la même chose pour les
Polonais l'Allemagne l'Allemagne vous en
parlez énormément dans dans votre livre
on comprend qu'elle ne prend pas la
menace au sérieux avant tout pour des
raisons économiques il y a le gaz russe
bon marché
dont elle est totalement dépendante
d'autant plus après Fukushima 2011 la
sortie allemande du du nucléaire on a
tous en tête hein la photo d'un Guerard
schreuder hilard futur patron de Gasprom
juste après avoir quitté on les voit là
le pouvoir voilà la colade avec Vladimir
pourquoi la France et et pourquoi
l'Allemagne pardon a persisté aussi sur
ce lien économique c'était vraiment
indispensable alors il y a plusieurs
raisons d'abord il y a un lien
historique entre l'Allemagne et la
Russie qui est très profond qu'on
connaît assez mal en
France mais c'est une relation beaucoup
plus complexe et profonde que la nôtre
nous notre relation avec la Russie c'est
assez historique c'est romantique c'est
culturel c'est stratégique aussi c'est
une question de de de conception de la
sécurité européenne
euh l'Allemagne il y a d'abord bon une
relation au 19e siècle ils sont beaucoup
plus proche géographiquement bien
entendu il y a aussi la deuxième guerre
mondiale où l'Allemagne évidemment a a
eu le rôle que l'on connaît avec le
régime nazi et Hitler et et très souvent
les responsables allemands quand vous
leur parlez de la Russie ils commencent
en disant vous savez l'Allemagne est
responsable de la mort de 20 millions de
soviétiques donc c'est quelque chose qui
est vraiment intégré dans leur
raisonnement il y a ce sentiment de
culpabilité aussi vis-à-vis de de l'URSS
qui est devenu en fait qu'ils ont
transposé à la Russie après l'éclatement
de de l'URSS parce que après tout parmi
ces 20 millions de morts il y a aussi
beaucoup d'Ukrainiens mais pour eux
c'est devenu les Russes voilà et puis il
y a aussi mélé à ça et c'est ça qui rend
cette relation complexe et intéressante
il y a aussi un sentiment de gratitude à
cause de la réunification finalement
c'est gorbachchov qui a qui a permis qui
ne s'est pas opposé à la R
ber donc il a tout ça qui qui se met
ensemble et puis il y a les intérêts
économique énorme plus important aussi
que les nôtres parce que nous nous
n'avions pas cette dépendance
énergétique puisque nous avons développé
l'énergie nucléaire la France les
Allemands ne voulaient pas du nucléire
comme vous l'avez dit en particulier
après Fukushima Angela Merkel a décidé
d'accélérer le le le départ du nucléaire
il n'était pas prêt encore les les
énergies de nouvell n'était pas encore
assez performante pour assurer la
transition énergétique donc le seul la
seule énergie la seule source qui
pouvait assurer cette transition
énergétique c'était le gaz le gaz russe
ils en avaient coulé à flot et il était
pas cher et les milliards d'euros dans
les infrastructures de nstream 1
notamment voà et l'industrie allemande
très puissante et très énergivore très
très consommatrice de gaz russe donc
elle faisait pression aussi sur Merkel
pour la France vous le disiez Sylvie
Koffman a aussi pâti d'une russophilie
très puissante dans toutes ses élite un
peu d'anti-américanisme aussi qui a
tourné bien souvent ces élites vers
l'Est est-ce que c'est ça qui a
contribué aussi à une forme
d'aveuglement d'Emmanuel Macron vous
passez beaucoup de temps à essayer de
décortiquer cette cé cité il en est
sorti mais est-ce que c'est cette
russophilie qui lui a fait penser qu'il
fallait continuer à parler à Poutine
parler de ne pas l'humilier donner des
garanties de sécurité avant finalement
de pouvoir dire il faut que
soit défait alors la russophilie je
l'attribuerai plus alors c'est c'est
c'est un terme qui est difficile parce
que après tout il y a il y a rien de mal
à être russophile les Russes sont des
gens voilà sont des gens tout à fait
intéressants et respectables c'est c'est
mais le problème c'est quand cette
russophilie s'est transformée en
poutinophilie en réalité hein puisquon
avait là un dirigeant qui dont on voyait
bien si on regarde on voyit bien les
défauts et les dérives et et et les
ambitions euh et et et c'est c'est le
problème de cet aveuglement que je
dénonce la Macron je pense que c'est une
il était assez fasciné par par la Russie
comme comme la plupart des présidents
françaisin j'ai j'ai retrouvé dans dans
des discours de Chirak cette expression
il ne faut pas humilier la Russie on a
beaucoup reproché à Emmanuel Macron en
particulier au moment où où la guerre a
commencé et puis il y avait cette idée
qu'il n'a cessé de répéter qu'il fallait
arrimer la Russie à l'Europe la fameuse
architecture voilà cette ambition et ça
c'était vraiment je crois la la
motivation de de Macron cette ambition
de reconstruire une architecture de
sécurité européenne puisque qui était en
train de s'effondrer après la la fin de
la guerre froide et et C pour lui
reconstruire cette sécurité cette
architecture de sécurité européenne ne
pouvait se faire qu'avec la Russie qui
est comme la France une puissance
nucléaire avec laquelle on devait
pouvoir parler d'égal à égal et et qui
était un maillon essentiel pour lui de
cette sécurité et on voit maintenant
qu'après la guerre en Ukraine en réalité
si un jour on reconstruit cette sécurité
européenne cette architecture de
sécurité européenne ça sera plutôt
contre la Russie qu'avec la Russie ouis
et c'est très intéressant tout ça peut
se comprendre et on va assez vite on ne
peut pas se comprendre sans le le repli
américain vous y consacrez vos premiers
chapitres pour terminer Sylvie Koffman
la journamento qui le fait le mieux
maintenant qu'on est sorti de
l'aveuglement est-ce que les Allemands
le font mieux ce cette autocritique que
que nous ou pas alors oui d'abord le
débat est beaucoup plus vigoureux en
Allemagne que chez nous ça c'est vrai
chez nous il y a assez peu de débat sur
notre politiques russes
passé en en Allemagne c'est un débat
très très vigoureux depuis le début de
de de la guerre en Ukraine l'invasion
russe de l'Ukraine a énormément secoué
les Allemands ça remis en cause les
piliers vraiment des fondements de leur
politique extérieure de leur politique
énergétique bien sûr puisqu'ils ont dû
en espace d'un an apprendre à se passer
du gaz russe et donc ils ont commencé ce
travail de réouverture de c'est c'est
assez lent c'est assez lent je crois
parce que justement il y avait beaucoup
plus en jeu pour eux dans la relation
avec la Russie c'est plus compliqué que
pour nous merci beaucoup Syvie kman
c'est absolument passionnant c'est aussi
d'une certaine façon le livre de votre
vie vous avez commencé tout jeune
correspondante à Moscou à Varsovie vous
avez même rencontré sakarov cor-il dit
de cette Russie Poutin d'aujourd'hui les
aveuglés comment Berlin et Paris ont
laissé la voie libre à la Russie c'est à
lire chez Stock vous restez avec moi
c'est l'heure des affranchis pour leur
parti pris on les accueille tout de
suite bienvenue les affranchis Nathan de
vert le philosophe de savourgarde sur
LCP asseyez-vous et Thomas Lestavel pour
l'air du temps d'une certaine façon une
chronique société aujourd'hui on
commence par Bourbon Express l'histoire
du jour à l'Assemblée c'est vous les
Amond d'ingava qui nous la racontez
bonsoir
bonsoir je vais vous raconter l'histoire
de la tension ici à l'Assemblée elle a
toujours existé elle redouble depuis un
an et on s'est demandé si elle avait pas
franchi un nouveau cap sur fond de
conflit
israélo-palestinien comment vous la
qualifiez vous l'ambiance en ce moment à
l'Assemblée B allez un peu à l'image de
l'ambiance de notre pays c'est-à-dire
énormément de tension les gens se
défoulent alors est-ce que c'est bien il
y a un moment faut que ça sorte quelque
part est-ce que il faut que ça se
termine par des insultes ou des noms
d'oiseaux la réponse est non on a vu des
invectives dans l'hémicycle qui ne sont
pas dignes de la représentation
nationale j'insiste bien sur
l'exemplarité des parlementaires parce
que les Français nous rgarde et beaucoup
de députés qu'on a croisé aux quatre
colonnes cet après-midi avec Ivan
anavion avaiit désigné dé fautifs
laattention elle est due aux insoumis on
n'est pas sur des questions qui sont des
questions politiques on n'est pas sur on
est pour on est contre un texte sur la
question du du Proche Orient on est sur
des positions qui sont des positions
antisémites antirépublicaine de la part
de la France insoumise j'ai de plus en
plus de mal avec certains à l'extrême
gauche parce que parce que leur attitude
des des dernières semaines est pour moi
inadmissible et même irresponsable vous
dites qu'avant vous discutiez avec
certains députés à soumi mais que
maintenant c'est plus possible ça dépend
euh ça dépend euh il y a certains avec
qui je peux encore discuter euh voilà il
y a euh parce que je sais qu'ils sont
euh pas complètement sur la ligne
mélanchoniste de de ce conflit permanent
les insoumis mis en cause droit de
réponse de Manuel Bompard des députés
nous disent que l'ambiance est encore
plus tendu qu'avant et disent il y a un
responsable c'est les insoumis oui de
toute façon j'ai bien compris que les
insoumis sont responsable de tout tout
le temps ce que j'observe c'est que dans
les débats par exemple celui qui a eu
lieu lundi ou lors des questions au
Gouvernement l'attitude des députés
macronist des députés de droite des
députés d'extrême droite à l'égard des
députés de la France insoumise quand il
s'exprime et intolérable et inacceptable
et que ce ne serait accepté de euh de la
part d'aucun député et puis ce qu'on
observe aussi depuis le 7 octobre ici à
l'Assemblée euh c'est destension à
l'intérieur même des groupes politiques
oui au sein des groupes on a beaucoup
parlé du conflit ouvert au sein de la
nupes je vais pas y revenir ce soir mais
sachez qu'il y a aussi des débats au
sein de la majorité lundi dernier il y a
eu un débat ici à l'Assemblée sur la
situation au proche- Orient un discours
du président de la commission des
affaires étrangères à la assemblé le
modème Jean-Louis bourlange regardez
applaudissement nourri sur les bans de
la gauche un peu moins applaudi sur les
bans de la majorité son discours a
hérité certains députés Renaissance il
trouvait qu'il pointait trop de
responsabilité du côté du gouvernement
israélien mardi matin à la réunion du
groupe Renaissance certains ont aussi et
bien regretté que le groupe prenne des
positions trop pro israéliennes un
équilibre qui est très difficile à
trouver entre députés même d'un même
groupe est-ce que là la tension elle est
vraiment plus palpable encore que celle
qu'on a connu avant oui bien sûr et
parfois les même vous le dites très
justement au sein d'un même groupe parce
que je vous le dis encore une fois
chacun arrive avec sa sensibilité sa
propre histoire et son regard sur ce
conflit et donc ça rend les les les les
échanges très compliqués donc déjà
pendant les retraitees on se disait
qu'on avait jamais connu un tel niveau
de tension là c'est le voilà le conflit
le plus passionnel depuis toujours voilà
on a monté d'un cran jusqu'à quand ça
peut tenir tout le monde se pose la
question personne n'a la réponse merci
beaucoup Elsa on continue d'une certaine
façon à part parler de cette guerre
entre Israël et le et le ramas avec vous
Nathan de vert vous vouliez revenir sur
le traitement médiatique de l'explosion
qui a touché à l'hôpital àalie de Gaza
le 17 octobre oui c'est un événement qui
est survenu la semaine dernière alors
pour rappeler brièvement les fait donc
nous sommes le 17 octobre début de
soirée et on apprend que une explosion
versus une frappe a touché l'hôpital
Halali dans la bande de Gaza hôpital où
c'était réfugié dans la cour beaucoup de
civils qui fuyaient les bombardements
israéliens aussitôt la nouvelle tombée
quasiment instantanément deux versions
antagonistes surgissent la version du
Hamas accusant Israël et parlant d'au
moins 200 morts et la version d'Israël
démentant ces accusations et disant très
vite que c'est une requette
palestinienne alors depuis une semaine
initialement c'était paroles contre
pararole bon les enquêtes
journalistiques ont été faites un peu
dans le monde entier et globalement elle
tente à établir que c'était pas une
frappe aérienne mais que c'était très
très probablement une requettete
Palestinienne même s' encore il faut
être un peu prudent parce qu'il y a
encore quelques hésitations sur le
déroul exact des faits mais moi je
voulais parler non pas tellement de
l'événement lui-même mais de sa
perception parce que ce qui est
intéressant c'est que le soir même quand
nous nagions en pleine incertitude quand
nous ne savions pas c'était parole
contre parole objectivement
incontestablement c'est la version du
Hamas qui a gagné dans l'opinion
publique et ce pour deux raisons d'abord
parce qu'il y a beaucoup de médias
internationaux qui ont repris les
données du ministère de la santé sans
dire queil était de Gaza sans dire qu'il
était administré paras deuxièmement
parce que un certain nombre de
politiques en France ont fait des tweets
notamment en accusant Israël et les pas
retiré et troisièmement d'ailleurs parce
que il y a eu des manifestations dans le
monde entier dans la nuit du 17 au 18
octobre alors qu'est-ce que cela dit
précisément selon vous sur la place de
la vérité en temps de guerre alors il y
aurait deux hypothèses l'hypothèse
majoritaire j'ai lu un peu les
éditoriaux et les les articles qui ont
été écrit à ce sujet c'est d'invoquer le
concept de post vérité c'est veàut dire
de dire qu'on vit dans un monde où il y
a que des croyances des visions du Réel
qui s'affich qui qui s'affrontent et que
on se soucie pas de leur vérification
qui aurait donc une sorte de relativisme
où on mettrait sur le même plan la
parole d'une société démocratique
pratique où des contrepouvoirs peuvent
d'ailleurs identifier les mensonges du
gouvernement et celle d'une société sans
contre-pouvoir sans presse libre sans
liberté d'expression et moi je tique un
peu avec ce concept pour tout vous dire
de fase vérité pour une raison très
simple c'est que des facto la vérité
elle existe et on la voit aujourd'hui
que le travail de vérité est en train de
s'établir et que d'ici quelques mois
elle sera totalement posée il me semble
qu'il y a un concept qui est plus
pertinent c'est le concept proposé par
le philosophe Christophe bouton dans son
dernier livre l'accélération de
l'histoire le concept de polycronie il
dit en fait que notre époque est
travaillé par plusieurs régimes
d'historicité qui sont concurrents
plusieurs temporalités comme ça qui
rentrent en rivalité et qu'en
l'occurrence ici ce qu'on voit bien
c'est qu'il y a une temporalité qui est
celle d'un présentéisme absolu celle des
réseaux sociaux en effet avec le
relativisme qui va de Perre et qui a une
autre temporalité beaucoup plus lente et
donc beaucoup plus faible en fait de la
vérification du fact checking et à terme
de la pensée critique et il me semble
que la vraie inquiétude qu'il faudrait
avoir c'est de se dire pourquoi cette
temporalité là de la prudence de la
patience et de la critique est en fait
moins efficace politiquement est moins
forte politiquement que la temporalité
présentéiste écoute ça c'est ça demande
carrément une bonne heure d'émission
j'ai pas le temps de vous faire réagir
j'en suis un peu frustrée parce que je
suis sûr que çaar était passionnant mais
il faut qu'on laisse le temps à Thomas
Lestavel de sa de sa chronique alors ce
soir vous voulez nous parler de la
Française des jeux qui avec ses
homologues dans se autres pays viennent
de lancer un nouveau jeu s'appelle
eurodreams petit frère de l'euromillion
c'est une bonne nouvelle ou pas pour
vous normalement vous faites l'économie
ça ça devrait rapporter de l'argent à
l'état alors effectivement si on
commence par l'économie un peu à courte
vue on va dire c'est une bonne nouvelle
les jeux de hasard rapportent beaucoup
d'argent à l'état près de 6 milliards
d'euros par an et d'après un rapport de
la Cour de comptes qui est qui est sorti
le mois dernier d'ailleurs près d'un
adulte sur de jou donc pour beaucoup
c'est un passemp occasionnel mais on
sait pour certains ça devient une
véritable addiction d'autant qu'on a vu
d'autres jeux apparaître en ligne voilà
et c'est là qu'on arrive sur le sujet
plutôt santé on va dire alors ces sites
en ligne donc certains sont Lau et on
les connaît bien comme B click mais on a
également les casinos en ligne donc de
type machine à sous ou blackjack sur
Internet et ça c'est totalement illégal
pourtant 3 millions de Français jouent à
ces jeux en fait c'est des casinos
virtuels donc qui se multiplient en ce
moment qui sont hébergés aux Caraïbes et
à Malte notamment à Malte où l'argent
est blanchi par des banques qui ferment
les yeux eu et parfois au profit de
mafia comme Cosan nostra la chaîne t
d'ailleurs a diffusé cet été un
documentaire très édifiant sur le sujet
si vous voulez regarder et au passage
pour revenir à l'économie c'est quand
même plusieurs milliards ur de recettes
en ligne qui échappe totalement au
fisque et c'est évidemment très grave
alors c'est une catastrophe au niveau de
la santé mentale ces sites illégau sont
accessibles à tous même aux ados qui
sont particulièrement vulnérables et on
sait que l'addiction au jeu est un vrai
calvaire alors le scénario typique he
c'est vous jouez de manière
obsessionnelle vous prenez plus de
plaisir vous sortez plus vous vous
isolez de vos proches parfois même vous
développez d'autres addictions comme le
tabac ou l'alcool d'après l'association
SOS joueur les problèmes mentaux liés à
ces fameux sites illégaux ont tri en
seulement 5 ans et environ 20 % des
joueurs excessifs qui débutent des soins
psychiatriques ont déjà commis une
tentative de suicide donc c'est vraiment
quelque chose de alors qu'est-ce qu'on
fait que font les pouvoirs publics alors
bah les pouvoirs publics justement ils
font pas grand-chose et c'est assez
étonnant il y a un projet de loi qui
vient d'être adopté en première lecture
pour entre guillemets sécuriser et
réguler l'espace numérique on a regardé
on n même pas trouvé une mention des
casinos en ligne alors que même le mois
dernier il y a un collectif
d'addictologues donc de médecins
spécialisés dans dans ces addictions qui
avait sonné l'alerte dans une tribune au
Figaro d'après eux les jeux d'argent en
ligne sont encore plus addictifs parce
qu'en fait on peut miser beaucoup plus
souvent et on est encore plus isolé on
va pas au PMU ou au casino les experts
parlent de cocaïne des jeux d'argent on
peut absolument pas rester l'xis devant
un tel drame on peut pas jouer à la
roulette russe sur un tel sujet de santé
publique merci beaucoup Thomas ESTAVEL
peut-être que cette chronique elle sera
entendue par un député qui s'en saisira
et qui déposera un amendement ça sera à
ça aussi la Chaîne Parlementaire merci
beaucoup Merci à VOUS Sylvie Kofman et
merci à Elsa qu'on retrouve très vite
les aveugl comment la France et
l'Allemagne est passé complètement à
côté du projet impérialiste de
déstabilisation de l'Occident de
Vladimir Poutine c'est passionnant et
c'est-à-dire chez STC très belle soirée
à vous documentaire qui commence avec
Jean-Pierre Gratien à
[Musique]
demain